the important decision was taken on
council conclusions on
bosnia-herzegovina as you know the
council agreed and invited the
Commission to start working on the
opinion on the bosnia-herzegovina
application for membership this is I
believe a good moment which makes clear
that the enlargement policy is credible
it means that we have seen
bosnia-herzegovina working hard on the
clearly defined conditions and
delivering on them I was led to notice
that many colleagues who intervene to
refer to the debate that took place last
friday in bratislava and at the same
time I can say that two of the points
from a road map that was adopted in
Brazil are will be on the agent of
European Council that is migration and
trade policy and the third point where
we today agreed will be on the agent in
October our relationship with with
Russia at the same time the Eco in the
council was it is extremely important
that we use the remaining time up until
them and finalize the preparations for
the signature of the free trade
agreement between European Union and
Canada we believe that the European
Council in October will be a successful
one when it comes to the overall
discussion on trade policy but also
finally in order to be able to sign a
setter agreement